non monsieur marc lefur pour le groupe
l'est républicain merci mme la
présidente
ma question s'adresse à vous monsieur le
premier ministre dispose et
d'entreprises sur nos territoires c'est
une chance
disposer d' entreprises dont les sièges
sociaux dont les directions sont ancrées
dans nos régions c'est encore une plus
grande chance surtout en ces périodes
d'instabilité
cette chance nous l'avons en bretagne
dans le réseau bancaire ou le crédit
agricole est présent dans chacun des
départements et où également existe
crédit mutuel de bretagne dont le siège
à proximité de brest est une référence
c'est une banque qui a su progressiez
qui a su innover
le problème c'est que le crédit mutuel
de bretagne aujourd'hui est sous la
menace d'une véritable au pea inamical
de la part d'un de ses concurrents le
groupe s'est hissé ce risque est
également lié à l'évolution de la
réglementation mutualiste décidées au
niveau européen
si le crédit mutuel de bretagne perdait
son autonomie ce serait une véritable
catastrophe
cela inquiète les épargnants qui sont
aussi des adhérents qui sont aussi des
propriétaires de fête du crédit mutuel
de bretagne
cela inquiète les salariés le groupe du
crédit mutuel arkéa compte neuf villes
salariés dont 6000 en bretagne les
autres en aquitaine et en auvergne
cela inquiète les entreprises en
particulier les pme qui perdrait un
interlocuteur local et qui verrait les
décisions les concernant
renvoyé à paris si je vous pose la
question monsieur le premier ministre
c'est qu'en dépit de mes interrogations
le ministère des finances qui est la
tutelle sur les banques ne répond pas
donc ce que nous souhaitons mes
collègues benoît le callennec lurton et
le ré c'est que vous ne répondiez est-ce
que vous saurez préserver un décideur
locale une banque régionale ou est-ce
que vous laisserez faire la
financiarisation qui nous menacent les
décisions à
et reviennent dans les jours les
semaines qui viennent monsieur le
premier ministre
j'attends de vous des décisions merci
monsieur le furent la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie
manuel macron merci madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le député je veux d'abord ici
vous rassurer l'implantation et
l'activité du crédit mutuel et en
particulier du crédit mutuel opérant en
bretagne n'est pas menacée par les
sujets dont vous faites état et sur
lesquels je vais revenir en détail et
donc les crédits qui sont octroyés à
l'économie de bretagne aux acteurs
industriels et en particulier de
l'agroalimentaire se sont aujourd'hui
entre autres ceux de ce groupe se seront
demain ceux de ce groupe ou d'un groupe
dont la gouvernance aura été revu la
deuxième chose est mon collègue michel
sapin y travaillent de manière régulière
et je vous prie ici d'excuser son
absence puisqu'il est en chine avec le
président de la république
mais vous savez vous savez monsieur le
député comme moi que depuis plusieurs
mois il y à des sujets au sein de la
fédération du crédit mutuel entre
différents organes qui ont été soulevées
par plusieurs acteurs qui sont en cours
de règlement ils ont fait l'objet de
travail détaillé avec la banque de
france les services de la banque de
france d'une part avec les services du
ministère des finances d'autre part que
compte tenu des choix qui ont été faits
pour résoudre pour résoudre la crise
grecque
aujourd'hui la supervision des banques
est au système européen des banques
centrales et que donc un examen est avec
ces derniers en cours nous garantissons
premièrement que la fiabilité du groupe
crédit mutuel et de la confédération
sera maintenu et c'est l'un des
objectifs qui sera poursuivie par le
ministère des finances
deuxièmement que la capacité du crédit
mutuel de bretagne à financer l'économie
de bretagne sera maintenu et qu'aucune
décision ne sera remonté à paris ou
ailleurs et que troisièmement dans le
respect de toutes les procédures de
gouvernance de régulation européennes la
bonne décision sera prise dans les
prochaines semaines avec précisément les
services européens et avec les services
du ministère des finances
des arbitrages seront faits mais ils
seront faits pour le bonne sinon
mende de l'économie française et en
particulier de l'économie bretonne
merci monsieur mis sa part est à
monsieur le paysage en poche